[Music]
welcome to cloud on air live webinars
from Google cloud we are hosting
webinars daily you're watching cloud 101
where speakers discuss the fundamental
concepts of Google cloud platform and
learn from the best practices in
different markets my name is Sonia
Kernan and today we will be talking
about kick starting your career in
Google cloud joining me today is Evan
Jones you can ask questions any time on
the platform and we have Googlers on
standby to answer them so let's get
started let's do it all right let's get
started with a presentation here and so
Evan you want to introduce yourself sure
I'm so those of you haven't seen my face
before I'm a big data machine learning
technical curriculum developer it's a
mouthful to say but honestly it's a
dream job I get to tinker way and build
some really cool labs and the best part
is we get to present the moment for you
today so not to give away a little bit
of the agenda later but we're gonna be
doing is playing a live interactive game
with prizes so make sure if you you know
you really want to get the most out of
this you definitely want to stick around
for that game at the end all right my
name is Sonia karna and I'm the global
lead for Google cloud learning in higher
ed my focus is to enable students in
higher education to tap into careers in
cloud with training and certification so
for these in here for today we're gonna
talk a little bit about careers in the
cloud I'll share my past experience of
how I got to Google cloud in general and
we're gonna share how literally in this
webinar right now throw out through this
game and a couple of the labs you're
gonna play you can start to develop
those skills they'll get you on the path
to building a career in the cloud and so
me I was also going to share some really
cool stats of if you get cloud certified
if you practice a lot of these labs it
actually is a tangible impact in the
marketplace for your next career which
is really cool I'll show you some of
some neat demos if you've never seen
Google cloud platform before there's
some really neat things that you can do
with machine learning with kubernetes
with bigquery so you're gonna see a
bunch of cool demos and I've hand
selected five labs as part of our game
for you to play along with us today at
any time during this webinar I see some
folks are already typing in the live
chat that makes me extremely happy as we
get the presentation on this laptop we
also have the live chat over here so I'm
like super thrilled got people from
Istanbul so if you wouldn't mind right
now
just say hi in that chat we have nan
Denis who's standing by to answer any of
your questions live but also the cool
thing is if you have a question that we
don't answer during today's session you
can post it to that thread and then Sami
or I will go in after the tech and make
sure you get those links with those
resources especially because later on
the presentation there's gonna be a
promotional link that's gonna give you
30 free days of quick labs so in
addition to your 12-hour game today
which is all free you can stick around
get that 30 free day link as well we'll
post that into this discussion thread
but before that we need to teach you a
bunch of really really cool stuff and
why it matters so first and foremost let
me talk to you about a little bit of my
path to Google a lot of people wonder
how did you end up at a at Google and a
job in Google and Google cloud so I went
to the College University of Maryland so
the East Coast in the US and my first
major was accounting and I'm like oh man
this is great I love working with
numbers and I was sitting in my 300
person accounting class and I decided
mmm doing a lot of this stuff by hand is
super hard so my first information
systems class you really showed me the
power of computing and how I can take a
lot of this logic and feed it into an
automated system and I basically learned
the language of the structured query
language or sequel and I absolutely fell
in love with it I could write queries
and build dashboards really just let the
computer do all the hard work which is
pretty fun so if you've ever worked with
spreadsheets or any kind of application
before where there's data you know that
you can unlock the power of that data by
using a query language that you're gonna
be learning a little bit more of today
after that I worked for a new Renewable
Energy Company and then really realized
that it wasn't physical goods I actually
worked for a solar panel manufacturer
I ended up dropping one of the solar
panels so I was just like I'm better for
you know sticking in the digital world
where I can't really bring well I can
break things but less easily and you can
always roll back the code as well so
then I joined a consulting firm in DC
Deloitte which is really really fun but
that eventually led me to Google
my first job is in Google finance
building pipelines and then I eventually
got a job in Google cloud and the really
cool thing about cloud is let me tell
you a little bit of a story in my first
database class flash back to the year
2008 it was a junior in college and the
professor dr. Weiss was talking to me
about how do you set up a schema how do
you load data in and what struck me was
really interesting is we were using
Microsoft Access at the time and in the
performance optimization section he had
to warn the class ok now you run the
query first and then you run the query
first and then only use a subset of the
data just you can get an idea for the
query and the back of my mind I'm like
why couldn't we all run the same query
at once why can't we all use a gigantic
data set why am i limited by my hardware
that my physical machine either on my
laptop or some server rack there and
then lo and behold a lot of other people
were having that problem and then Google
and a bunch of other cloud providers
have created these fully managed
services like if you've ever heard of
bigquery before you don't need to worry
about stacking in servers or managing
any of the hardware you just need to
remember this sequel or how to ask those
questions of your data and all the
hardware and all the query and all the
infrastructure is managed for you by
Google behind the scenes so instead of
you managing things and worrying about
things like concurrency or too many
people hitting your application you can
let Google manage that and build on
Google stack so that was really
interesting kind of full circle from 10
years of running a database in my laptop
to running a database in a bunch of data
centers around the world but I don't
need to see and I don't need to worry
about you're gonna be using bigquery
today in your in your lab that's
essentially what Google cloud allows you
to do you bring the great ideas Google
cloud literally the word is Google cloud
platform it builds you that platform it
makes those resources available to you
all these fun icons that you see here
are all the different technologies that
you can reach
access Google had to build them for
itself to solve to make the if you
remember a googles mission is to make
the information of the world universally
accessible so it had to solve it for
itself so then it created those
technologies available to you for you to
use on this platform so some stats by
the numbers always like thrown these out
in case you're wondering how big is
Google cloud platform and Google as a
whole over 1.2 billion photos are
uploaded every day for those of you use
Google photos yeah it's amazing it's
crazy right mind-boggling size yeah it's
a total size of if you haven't seen PB
before so it's megabyte gigabyte
terabyte which is a thousand gigabytes
and that thousand terabytes is one
petabyte and then you've got exabytes
and data bytes and that sort of thing
but that's 13 petabytes of data and if
you're looking at the other stat if
you're a youtuber one petabyte or over
400 hours of video end-to-end video is
uploaded to YouTube every minute it
would literally take a lifetime to start
watching all the videos that were
uploaded in a day or two this is crazy
too and all that think about the
infrastructure needed to maintain google
photos in YouTube that's what's
available to you for your applications
with Google cloud platform and you'll
experience that within your lab a little
bit later today also in addition to the
infrastructure there's all the
networking so the networking goes all
the cables and the technology that
allows the internet traffic through
Google to answer your queries through
Google search to upload your photos one
of my favorite things this is you see
the jiff of the the shark it's a dare I
say it's shark proof networking too but
it is some estimates it carries as much
as 40% of the world's Internet traffic
every day that's for your queries
YouTube all that kind of good stuff so
what are some of the cool technologies
that you can use that you're gonna see
in practice a little bit later in your
labs here's a demo that I'd like to show
you using one of my favorite ap is or
application programming interfaces using
what's the machine learning model for
identifying images this is my wife my
daughter and myself and earlier in the
year we were in New York City this is
just a couple months ago and it was
freezing as you can see we're bundling
up in front of Statue of Liberty so I
took this photo and I wanted to see what
Shiina learning can tell me about it
without having to build a model myself
so I uploaded into what's called the
vision API and immediately it says I
think this object here is a landmark
with 79% certainty I think it's a Statue
of Liberty also I'm gonna recognize that
faces in the photo and I recognize that
there's two faces but beyond that I can
see my wife's face because she's a
veteran of cold weather joy is very
likely my daughter on the other hand joy
is very unlikely because she was
freezing but what it did show that was
very likely that she was wearing a hat
so for common applications like working
with images processing out what's in
that image content there's a lot of
pre-built
models machine learning is just a way to
get computer intelligence based on a lot
of good training data and it also
recommends some kind of objects that are
in the photo as well and send some
descriptive labels as you see as I open
up the the labels in here as well and
that just shows just a general
application of machine learning you can
see that it says if I looked up this
image online it would recommend that it
was a Statue of Liberty you can access
this yourself if you are a developer and
you don't want to just drag and drop an
image into the web UI this is the JSON
request that you can just hit against
this API endpoint here and this is the
response that you can get why does that
matter
well the really cool part is if you
didn't want to just do one photo at a
time what you can do is that you can
actually send a batch request for
thousands of photos so I decided to do
next was I said alright let me find a
public collection of images and the Met
had a really good one and let's take a
look at over 200,000 images at the same
time and then feed all of them through
the vision API and see what we come up
with so we're using two technologies
here it's the vision API to get us
whether or not joy or surprise or anger
is likely is likely inside of these
photos and it's bigquery to store all
that data to allow us to query it you
don't really have to worry about too
much with the sequel and the queries
here I'll provide you the queries after
the fact that I'll show you I'll share
this demo with you as well but you can
see for each of the
images here we've got the image URL and
we also have the vision API is data so
you remember that JSON response that
showed whether or not something was like
my daughter was wearing the hat or if it
was a particularly large or if there's
likelihood of surprise you get that
response and you can query there was
200,000 images to do some really cool
things so this query inside a big query
says what are the different possible
attributes for joy and as you saw on
where was the highlighted squares the
shades of green you can see was very
likely to likely in this section of code
what this does is this shows find me the
image where surprised is most likely
from just an image of artwork these are
literally just photos and the Machine
says I think this piece of art looks
looks surprised and it says with about a
fifty four percent confidence again you
can kind of filter for your own
thresholds but this is with a piece of
the artwork the image that came up and
maybe he's probably surprised this is an
Italian pottery vendor from the Met
collection still I'd like to surprise
because you're killing way too many pots
and he's probably gonna break them but
you can see you can get tie in both the
doing insights at scale through machine
learning and also querying them inside a
big query now I'm super biased because
as you saw on my background this is all
data but you can imagine doing this in
your applications as well here's another
example ninety-eight percent confident
that they just fed this image and this
image it says is Yosemite now I can tell
you right now on the right you can see
that mountain right there that's El
Capitan here in Yosemite National Park
that is a heck of a climb up Half Dome
as well too but you can see just even
without writing a lot of custom machine
learning model code there's these tools
that you can reach out and get that
allow you to get the full benefit of
Google cloud platform now you may be
wondering ok you showed us a couple toy
examples of photos from vacation and
photos from the library how is Google
actually using these for our customers
today so a really cool application that
I like is Keller Williams who is a u.s.
real estate and realtor company what
they allow their professionals to do is
if you're a real estate agent and you're
selling houses
normally if you're going on a website
and you're a customer who wants to buy a
house you want to learn a little bit
about the features of the house does it
have granite countertops does it have
crown molding anything that you want to
care about for a house but manually
going through and tracking the inventory
for every single house's appliance is
this super boring job so one of the
things that you can do is you can point
your smartphone they've developed this
application and built on top of Google
Cloud Auto ml vision and point this
smartphone around at the house and let
it take that video and then it'll
automatically recognize objects and say
oh this house is in a modern style or I
recognize that these are granite
countertops and then it can turn that
automatically into a demo video so you
can just see like we went from
identifying whether or not you're
wearing a hat or not to just really
getting a full picture of all of the
things that make up a house and you can
see that it's it's much faster and
possibly more accurate and then doing it
yourself
also if you didn't like working with
images and you had a lot of natural text
maybe you're a kado which is the UK's
largest grocery online grocery supplier
and you want to filter certain messages
that are coming in for their sentiment
so someone sends something like positive
sentiment alcot oh I love your website
it's easy for me to do shopping in line
which is great but what happens it's
only sent in a chat saying hey I'm
really worried that the rain is gonna
affect my shipment for fresh vegetables
can you make sure that they arrive on
time maybe that sentiment is a little
bit more negative or something bad
happen with a shipment you can
proactively route those messages based
on their sentiment to the right person
so it's another example one last one
back to images if you're doing things
manually or there's a process by which
you think you can teach a machine to do
it this is another good example for you
so Q PI uses machine learning to sort
out essentially what it's gonna be the
ingredients for baby food so if you can
teach the machine by showing it lots of
good examples of what good food looks
like and bad food looks like and machine
learning we call that creating a
training data set then you can train a
model to help you help the human that's
doing these manouri reviews possibly do
it faster as well and that's exactly
what they do there so it's a lot of cool
applications but well now it's
transition to how you can actually get
those skills and get the mental map for
the
different avenues that you could pursue
inside of the cloud full use cases and
applications using Google cloud platform
heaven so thank you for walking us
through that Gartner has placed a Google
cloud platform in the leaders quadrant
as has Forrester Forrester recognizes
Google cloud as a leader in a few
different domains such as cloud native
security cloud native full-stack cloud
platforms as well as database as a
service so how can you tap into these
opportunities with Google cloud and
build some of the cool applications that
Evan showed us the best way to get
started is to learn and build something
and we have you know you're talking to
just the right people and we have role
based learning paths that you can
leverage to start learning about Google
Cloud Technologies so as you can see
here we have various role based learning
paths related to business cloud
infrastructure application development
data and machine learning as well as
team collaboration each of these has a
few different roles depending on your
you know whether you're an entry-level
developer or you've been around the
block for a few more years and you bring
that you know broader expertise and you
know you're really a practitioner of
technologies and you've built that you
know both the business acumen and
translating the business need into a
technical solution right so there's a
variety of training options that are
available to you that you can leverage
to start ramping up if you're trying to
switch careers and you're wondering you
know what is the foundational knowledge
that I need to get started in one of
these career paths generally if you're
in the cloud native application
development space or you know you're
looking at cloud infrastructure a good
place to start might be you know
JavaScript and Python skills are a
really good a solid foundation sequel
like I haven't talked about you know
sequel skills
give you a leg up and some bash shell
scripting chops will take you a long way
with cloud infrastructure skills as well
and you can't go wrong by skilling up on
open source technologies such as
kubernetes and Ten's tensorflow those
really give you transferable skills that
you can apply in multi cloud
environments and that's where most
enterprises are going today with open
open source technologies and multi cloud
or hybrid cloud environments absolutely
one of the things I'll tag on to the end
there is when we're doing resume review
for the people that applied for a lot of
Google positions one of the things that
I often look for is on your resume
naturally people have like links to
their phone number their an email
increasingly so people are looking for
the links to their github account and
that's not only can you consume these
open source technologies but if you
build something even just like a demo
application for school or for one of
your own personal projects and you
showed that not only you're passionate
about doing these games and taking these
labs but it's kind of like a capstone
project or an ending end-of-the-year
project for your courses if you're able
to show that code then somebody can
immediately say wow they really have
taken not only from learning but to the
actual application and that's what we're
gonna be practicing today is getting you
the skills to build those applications
by starting from a from a lab and so I
just want to add that cloud career paths
aren't limited to the technical roles
that are shown here right there are also
various other careers such as you know
technical program manager technical
account management technical writers
technical curriculum developers like
evan is today and i've been for several
years before i moved into this role all
of those you know with those roles if
you have technical skills they give you
a leg up you're able to build a more
persuasive case and you know appear more
confident when you're talking to
business stakeholders with those roles
you also need additional skills soft
skills such as in leadership influencing
stakeholders project management
communication and presentation skills
and so on but you know there's a place
for everybody
in respect to cloud related careers
absolutely yeah well said what I said
you want you need to really be
well-rounded alright let's talk about
the benefits yeah so training and
certification differentiate you from the
rest of the candidate pool you know so
there are tons of opportunities and then
there are tons of candidates as well so
how can you differentiate yourself from
the rest of the population
when you complete as well Google Cloud
specialization on Coursera you have the
option to share your as you may with
Google cloud as well as our hiring
partners so you know go ahead and take
the training complete a whole
specialization a specialization is
usually set of courses really in-depth
training related to a topic in addition
you know get certified certification
again differentiates you from the rest
of the population and proves to
employers that you meet a certain bar
you know in a recent study we found that
80% of those who applied for a new job
received at least one job offer
one in three certified users received a
raise or acquired a job for higher pay
so this is these are some really great
stats which show the value of Google
cloud our training and certification and
you know enable you to tap into the
careers in cloud I love those starts
okay so how can you get hands-on
experience working with these
technologies right now and we're gonna
do it in less than a half hour so again
at any point by the way you're gonna
follow along with me live here I'm gonna
explain how the game is gonna work but
if you have any questions we're gonna
post promotional links and anything else
in that discussion thread so make sure
you let your voice be heard so quick
labs what is quick labs quick labs is a
essentially like a sandbox environment
it's a it's a company that Google
acquired a couple years back and it's a
really awesome technology it's
essentially a platform for training and
what its gonna allow you to do is you're
gonna practice literally right after
this this live is it's gonna create a
real Google cloud platform account for
you to then do the labs so you
have two screens open or two tabs you're
gonna have the instructions for the lab
at hand picked my five favorite labs and
you can have the real Google cloud
platform it in the other window so let's
take a look at what that's gonna look
like inside of our game so before that
I'm gonna introduce you I already showed
you a bit about bigquery it's
essentially a really awesome place to
run your sequel on the cloud it's a date
data warehouse that scales to petabytes
of data but we'll cover that a lot more
inside of the game because I really want
to get you inside of the technology so
what are we can be doing inside of the
game so the game is gonna be one of the
five labs the whole game itself is the
five labs but we're gonna be doing one
together
I wrote this lab last year and what I
really wanted to show people was the
power of doing machine learning was just
writing a teeny bit of code literally
it's gonna be create a replacement model
and then you pick a model type which is
pretty awesome and the problem that
we're gonna solve for our marketing
analysts are and this is using real
Google merchandise store website data
Google Analytics data and this is the
website we can go to and buy cool Google
shirts but our problem is we want to say
which customers based on their behavior
on our site where they came from are
most likely to come back and buy
something from us now if you're a
marketer that's super valuable because
then you can say hey you abandoned your
card and everyone who's been on the
e-commerce world knows these kind of
tricks of marketers right if you've
added a product to the card you haven't
been to the website in a while or if
you're a loyalty user you might get
special perks and discounts we would
really want to identify those high-value
visitors and then promote to them how
can we do that with machine learning so
before we do that we need to get you set
up for the game so highlight in yellow
because it's probably one of the most
important slides you're gonna see today
I'd like everybody to go to google.com
SKU wik L ABS comm slash games slash 75
this is our 75th game this is the best
part of my job now you're gonna be met
with a modal it'll say I'll pop-up will
say after you click on join game a
pop-up will say hey knock knock what's
the password the password for today's
12-hour game and again we're just gonna
be doing one of the five labs in the
next half hour is kickstart
kick-starting your career in the cloud
all lowercase its case sensitive
so make sure you've got that I'll leave
this up for a few more seconds so I
talked a little bit more about the game
so as everyone's doing that now what the
game is is you're gonna be scoring
points based on completing objectives in
five labs and we'll walk through what
these objectives are for the labs that
we're gonna be covering it'll make a lot
more sense so don't panic though if
you're all I don't want to just you know
doing a lab inside of a 20-minute window
is too stressful you've got 12 hours to
take each of these five labs as many
times as you want now yes if you go
through a lab really quickly you get
bonus points for speed and then you can
show up on the leaderboard but we're
gonna walk through one of the labs you
see it together now I'm gonna be going a
little bit slower because I really I
want to teach you a little bit about the
technology as well but again on your own
time for the next 12 hours this game
winner it's gonna be active and you can
take each of these five labs that are
part of the game and there are five of
my absolute favorite labs so I'm gonna
go ahead and do that now so I've opened
up the game let me open this game URL I
see a few people already in the game I'm
this player number right here I want to
see this whole thing filled up we've got
300 slots for the game you're welcome to
just watch along if you if you prefer
but it's much more fun to get in the
action and play the game on this page
after you click join game click kick
start it'll ask you to sign in with your
Gmail account or create a new quick labs
account the cool thing about quick labs
is once you have this account and you
complete these games to complete these
labs you get badges that you can there
to share it share on your LinkedIn or
other career site so it's a quantifiable
way to say that you have experience in
these technologies and the cool part is
everybody that's on the webinar today if
you complete all of these labs you'll
get a special one-time only
edu badge that our graphic designer
Marissa created which is pretty awesome
and this is literally only gonna be
available for the next
twelve hours and if that doesn't
incentivize you enough the top-scoring
people for this lab will also get
additional free credits to take more
labs in the future also I didn't realize
it was a limited every one years are
perked up now it's a limited-edition
badge all right cool I mean if you're
not a competitive person and you're a
hoarder like I am and you just want to
collect cool things collect these badges
I can already see we added the screen
response we have folks joining and again
I'm going a little bit slow here just to
give people time and getting there if
you add a page where it says start lab
we're gonna be there soon can you repeat
the URL and the access code there's a
couple of people on the absolutely no
worries I'm gonna flash this back up
everyone just got their coffee and it's
coming back way the games starting so
before we go on make sure everyone's at
the same starting time it's gonna be
Google Doc quick labs QW ikl ABS comm
slash game slide 75 this is only
available for the next 12 hours this
special code is kick start all lowercase
and if somebody wouldn't mind just
pasting this into the discussion chat I
would be in your debt and I'm gonna
explain what a lab is keys are gonna see
some timers in just a second okay so
going back to the lab material so the
entire game is all five labs I'm gonna
zoom in here we're only gonna do one
today because we've got about a half
hour left and we're gonna do one of my
favorite ones but how the game works is
you can score points for completing
objectives in each of the five labs in
order to get that special badge you need
to do all five of the labs now if you
look at the ETA for each of the labs
it's pretty genuine generous so it's one
two three maybe four or four and a half
hours and honestly some of these labs
the fastest people can do them in about
10 to 15 minutes each as well and again
you can take each lab multiple times why
don't we keep saying that you can take
each lab multiple times well the lab
that I want you to click on is this one
predict visitor purchases with a
classification model in bigquery machine
learning and again that's that third lab
I don't want you to click on that first
one you can learn sequel and bigquery
and the basics on your own time later on
today what I really want you to focus on
is this really really cool machine
learning one so everybody click on the
predict visitor purchases with the
classification model I can see there's a
lot of people already in the game some
people are already getting ready to
score points I'm at the bottom of the
totem pole here so this is the
leaderboard I can see a bunch of already
people joining it so hi from beautiful
Sunnyvale California so what this lab
does is as soon as you click star lab so
it's all do it together and don't worry
I won't take you an hour and fifteen
minutes we're gonna do it in less than
30 minutes we're going to click on start
lab and this is provisioning a Google
cloud platform account for you behind
the scenes so the next thing I want you
to do is open up an incognito window
incognito window inside of Chrome and
once you've done that I want you to go
to console console dot cloud.google.com
console dot cloud.google.com there's
also a big button inside of the lab that
says open Google Cloud console the thing
why you want to do it in an incognito
window is if you use Gmail or if use
other Google services you don't want to
sign in with your personal account
because you're gonna be given a student
account that elects you to use the
Google cloud platform for free and
having an incognito window allows you to
do that without having to worry about
shifting back between things so now what
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna go back I'm
gonna copy and paste my username with
this little copy button right here I'm
gonna paste it in and that's your quit
this is different for you and then it's
gonna ask our password it's an
auto-generated password don't worry
about why I'm gonna do right now I'm
just gonna quickly hide in CSS so nobody
control me live on the webinar unless
you're gonna read one pixel font you
copy in your password
and then boom welcome to your new Google
cloud platform account kind of wild
right so let's accept the Terms of
Service together and again once you do
one of these labs you'll blaze through
this startup it'll look super familiar
it's a new account each time agree to
the Terms of Service agree and continue
if you're at a place where you see a big
blue bar at the top that says Google
cloud platform you know you're in the
right place again let's review the steps
consult cloud google.com in an incognito
window so you have two windows open
you've got your lab instructions and the
lab we're doing today is predict visitor
purchases with a classification model in
bigquery machine learning you've already
clicked start lab and then on that open
Google Cloud console in the incognito
you're not signing in with your personal
gmail account you're signing in with
this auto-generated username right here
and you're pasting that in to sign in
and then you're coming back and copy and
pasting the password now I see a lot of
people are in here which is excellent so
now like I mentioned before you've got
the two screens
you've got lab instructions as you start
to scroll down and these labs are all
step by step by step by step so even if
you don't have a background in sequel
you don't have a background of machine
learning absolutely fun you're still
gonna be able to do the lab the same way
as anybody else and the good news is we
provide a lot of links and instruction
to make sure that you're on the same
playing field as people who have a very
experienced in sequel so now we got the
lab instructions I'm gonna ask you to do
is have that open in one window in the
other window this is the real Google
cloud platform now you only have access
to this project this platform for the
duration of the lab so you don't get
access to this forever so this one is
only available until that timer hits
zero on your start lab and lab so let's
go ahead and get started with the actual
game so the first thing I want you to do
is make sure we're on our auto-generated
project so I'm gonna click on in the
upper left hand corner I'm gonna zoom in
a little bit so you guys can see a
little bit easier select a project and
the one that you want is should be all
way at the bottom it's quick labs GCP
alphanumeric characters a project in
Google cloud platform is essentially a
collection of resources that you're
gonna be using bigquery's a resource
machine learning like vision API is a
resource so click on that and now if you
open or expand the navigation menu these
are all the tools in our toolbox that we
can begin to build really cool
applications with now my favorite since
naturally bias and I come from a big
data background if you scroll Scroll
scroll Scroll scroll all the way down
the only one that we're gonna be using
today to do both data analysis and
machine learning is bigquery if you've
experienced it again this is under Big
Data bigquery one of the things that you
can do as well is you can pin it if you
pin it it actually bookmarks it or
highlights it all the way at the top for
you so if this is your own Google cloud
platform project account in the future
you can avoid doing tons of scrolling
because there's a tons of products but I
don't like scrolling that much so let's
get into bigquery welcome to new
bigquery UI great click done once you're
in here essentially what bigquery allows
you to do the left side is all about
what data you're pulling from the right
side is all about what query it's a
blank canvas which is a little bit
terrifying for somebody who may be rusty
its sequel hasn't done a lot in a while
so I'm gonna get you over that nervous
nervousness by saying all capital
letters select I just want you to say
select your name and your name is a
string which just means it's kind of
like alphabetic characters it's not
going to be a number so we need to put
it in single quotes or double quotes as
long as you're consistent it doesn't
really matter and I want you to click
run if you've never ran sequel before
you've now ran your first sequel
statement and the crazy part is you're
gonna go from never running a sequel
statement before to running sequel and
building not one but two machine
learning models in the next 20 minutes
it's kind of wild so you have your query
right here and below you've got your
query results a lot of people might be
wondering what on earth is the column f0
well those of you familiar with sequel
we can add an alias which is essentially
a column name up top here and now it's
just saying hard code this value just
returned this value and then give the
column a name boom and that's how you
get rows and columns now it's not really
that fun with just hey just return what
I'm saying we want to pull some data
from an existing data source now you
don't have to do what I'm doing I'm just
going to show you so I'm going to search
for the Google merchandise store it's
the crazy part is this Google
merchandise store it's literally the
store that sells things like Google pens
and
and that type of stuff which is
sometimes prizes for these games which
is great Google does a lot of what I
call dog fooding which means they use
their products on their own services and
businesses so the Google merchandise
store their Google Analytics account and
Google Analytics is a way of tracking
user behavior on a website marketers
know all about it is actually stored
inside a big query the actual Google
Analytics account which is crazy so what
I want you to do is we're gonna delete
this query and I'm gonna go back to the
lab instructions and we're gonna follow
along so we've already done all of this
we already have completed the bigquery
and what I want you to do is we will
copy this link which is the console of
cloud cuckoo Google com with that
specific project I'm gonna go back here
for ease of use so I'm just gonna open
up a new tab and paste it why are we
doing all this because if we have a data
set that already exists what you can do
is you can just gain access to it this
is public so it's available to everybody
your data sets by default aren't not
naturally not going to be public which
is good for you but this gives you
access to a data set that I've already
created that has our Google Analytics
data inside of it so now let's continue
on with the lab and again to repeat that
you've copied and pasted this in a new
tab and then now you're going to be
you're gonna have the actual data to
insights data here and inside if you
expand that you can actually see some
really cool datasets the e-commerce one
is going to be our focus for today's lab
so let's scroll down we're going to
explore the e-commerce data set so you
can explore structured data by using the
structured query language it's a fancy
sequel as a fancy way of just asking
questions in your data so let's ask some
questions out of the total visitors who
visited that store that I just showed
you what percentage made a purchase and
before I run this query I want a couple
brave souls to answer in the chat what
you think a high conversion rate is for
an e-commerce website so out of a
hundred people that visit your shopping
website
how many of them out of a hundred do you
think actually make a purchase rich
versus just surf on your website so
think about that get a number between 1
and 100 inside of your head for a
conversion rate and then we're going to
calculate it with sequel just by running
this query that we created for you so
once you've got your answer let's take a
look at what we actually return so out
of 741 thousand visits we have twenty
thousand purchasers you multiply this by
a hundred you'll see that's two point
six nine or two point seven percent yeah
amazing
and I wouldn't have expected it to be
that low yeah that's crazy number in my
head was closer to like thirty or forty
percent business you got a forty percent
conversion rate so if you're an
e-commerce professional I'm sure some
folks have already answered on chat
three to five percent is about what you
expect to convert and the cool part is
let's see if we can't find those people
who may or may not have bought on their
first visit but are likely to buy in a
second visit so start to think about
some of the data pieces that you could
know about a user that's gonna make it
unlikely to buy and think about your own
experience what what behavior would you
kind of do on the on the website that
would make you a kind of loyal customer
but before we do that let's take a look
at some of the products that we're
selling so copy and paste the I'm again
I'm just once you hover over this black
box
you go clicking on the copy button and
the lab instructions will be available
for you for the next twelve hours again
and the lab is a public lab in the
catalog so I'm gonna give you the promo
link at the end of this webinar where
you get 30 days free quick labs so don't
worry if you're worried about like and I
gonna lose access to the instructions or
anything like that so top five products
and again we're just doing a some on
revenue by product in this particular
case a lot of nest products are super
popular and you can see the total amount
that we're sold in the actual revenue
it's pretty wild you can see the most
popular one is the thermostat followed
by the outdoor security camera people
want don't want people breaking into
their houses and if they do next best
thing as an indoor and then they're
worried about smoke less apparently
it's just that's not Google approved
talk so how many visitors bought on
subsequent visits to the website so
we're gonna copy and paste this one and
this is where the Foundation's are all
of our objective for the machine
learning model is gonna come into play
so you don't even really worry too much
about the code but it's just saying if
they've made a transaction there's a
field in Google Analytics and by the way
this schema schema is a fancy way of
saying rows and columns and what the
columns mean if this the schema for
Google Analytics for this website for
the Google Analytics merchandise store
is the exact same for any other site
that uses Google Analytics so the if you
want to work on your own website and
apply this same logic you can the scheme
is gonna be the same so if they have
future transactions how do I know it's
feature because I'm just gonna tell you
right now it's a field in a schema
called new visits is null meaning if the
new visits field is flag is 1 that means
it's our first visit if it's blank then
it's their subsequent visit if it's if
they bought on a future visit flag them
as a 1 we're gonna mark them as a return
visit so I'm going to show you what that
looks like when people are racing ahead
of you this somebody who's finished it
alive somebody finished I love it
I'm mad you do it you're doing great
work so the the trick to these labs
again is I'm going through this pretty
slowly but what you're gonna realize is
after you execute this query so you can
see we have a split these are the
visitors this is the amount of those
visitors that total populations will buy
and a return visit and we want to be
able to predict that I love that people
are racing ahead in the lab that's cool
so inside of the quick labs how you can
earn the most points by the way is
there's certain milestones where you
click a button and it says hey have you
completed the lab steps up until this
checkpoint the faster you actually run
through the lab and click those you get
a speed bonus for your points over here
on the right so you can say I'm at is
just crushing it with 72 million points
right here and don't worry if you feel
like Evan you're purposely holding us
back by going so slowly don't worry
you've got 12 hours you can always don't
do this now but when you're done with
this lab you can click end lab and a
start lab button the green look button
will be there again
fire up the lab
Lay's through it as fast as he did and
then try to beat his score as well so
again you have multiple attempts to take
each of these labs so let's keep going
so we want to paste in the next query
and the next query again is under
selecting features in creating your
training data set my training data set
for machine learning is basically saying
I know a lot of things in the past can I
use those for predictive power in the
future so there's a couple of things
that you know about a visitor when they
visit your website are they going to
leave immediately in the e-commerce
world that's called a bounce meaning
they get to your site in less than 5
seconds passes and like whoa I don't
want to buy any Google of merchandise I
was looking for something else and I
immediately leave and then you might be
thinking and this is where the
technology piece is great bigquery is
great but it's really your brain and
your decision-making power that's gonna
be guiding you through the rest of this
lab because I need you to think about
what are some of the things that you can
know about a user for whether or not
they're gonna come back your website and
purchase so I just threw together time
on site like if they spend a ton of time
on your website is that a good proxy for
the machine learning model to learn the
behavior if they spent five hours on my
website or three hours maybe they're
really interested maybe they're not so I
want you to think about what I'm gonna
show you here we're gonna build a model
using just two of these columns by the
way machine learning speak if you're
feeding in model inputs to the model
these are your columns or your inputs
those are just called features of the
model features inputs columns all mean
the same thing for our structured data
use case so now you're a machine
learning scientist now which is pretty
cool so think we're just passing in two
fields and saying if you know the
balances and the time on-site
historically because again good quality
training data is the foundation for any
machine learning model can I predict
what I'm gonna buy in a future visit and
you can see that even though they spent
fifteen thousand seconds or three hours
in the site they didn't buy and the
return visit so what I'm gonna show you
and the big crux of this talk is that
it's easy to create a machine learning
model it's hard to create a good
high-performing machine learning model
but we're going to create one
nonetheless on just those three columns
so what I want you to do first is we
need a place to store those models we
use it we're gonna create what's called
a data set so everybody click on the
project this is your project don't click
on data insights that's my project click
on create data set a data set is just a
container it's a container for tables
models views and I want you to call it
ecommerce you have to call it ecommerce
if you want to use my queries in the lab
or else it'll break so make sure you
type in ecommerce all lowercase create a
dataset once you've done that I can
click go to or you can toggle this open
it's got nothing in there right now
so let's fill it up with a model so from
here on out we're gonna go a little bit
quicker so I'm gonna delete the query
that I had before I'm pasting in this
same query so what in bigquery but you
can do is I've highlighted it row 8
through the end I can click the down
arrow I can run the selected I'm passing
in data to a machine learning model what
data are we are we passing in and again
you've seen this before it's just
looking to see whether or not I have my
time on site and my whether or not they
balance immediately has a good
predictive power so I've got that and
now I want to create a model off of that
so the model code everybody on this call
can create a machine learning model and
you're gonna do it right now the code is
just saying create replace models stored
in my e-commerce data set that you just
created call it classification model
this is me model number one which spoil
alert its me a really bad performing
model we're using a logistic regression
you don't need to really need to know
this there's more information in the
labs but logistic regression is a good
model option if you're doing what's
called classification classification is
saying I have one class of users that
say I'm gonna purchase on a return visit
I have another class of users that
aren't going to purchase I've got two
different buckets for a new user that's
coming in the future which bucket should
they fall into it's called
classification a model type is
essentially a bunch of math that goes on
behind the scenes logistic regression is
a fine one to start with and what are we
predicting on that's your label a label
is what you know in the past and what
you're predicting on in the future
so we're feeding in a bunch of known
values for whether or not they're gonna
buy historically and in the future we're
gonna be predicting on that value
right now I'm gonna ask you to run that
query that's gonna create the model and
what I'm gonna ask you to do while
that's running I'm gonna ask you to open
up a new tab because I'm gonna get you
to create a second model at the same
time so I'm gonna run two models
concurrently and I want to explain what
the difference is between model one and
model two are so getting a recap you got
one model running you can see query
history one running and I got a blank
canvas right here I want you to scroll
down or click in the sidebar on this
section that says improve of model
performance with feature engineering
it's a very fancy way of saying hey
those two columns just saying whether or
not someone's sat on your website page
your homepage for three hours and not
moved anywhere might not give a lot of
predictive power to the machine learning
model let's see if we can throw in some
additional data so you know you're in
the right spot in the lab if it says
create a replacement model ecommerce
classification model number two so go
ahead and copy that code paste that and
then that in and then run that machine
learning models if you haven't worked
with machine learning before some of the
best and the brightest ones could take
hours or even days for some of the huge
models here at Google these models are
gonna run and less than five to ten
minutes which is absurd when it comes to
creating your first machine learning
model so I passed I would have expected
that a sequel programmer would need or
would only be interested in this kind of
data or be able to produce this kind of
data but it now seems like a marketing
analyst or a business intelligence
professional might be interested or
perhaps now has the tool tool set to you
know produces kinds of predictive
analysis and so on right which is really
amazing you're not relying on your IT
teams anymore to give you the data
that's it
and that's the biggest shift as I
mentioned like ten years ago you had to
manage both the optimization of the
database like making sure not too many
people are running queries at the same
time and whether or not you'd have
enough storage on your hard drive and
then you had to rely on your data
science professionals to create the
machine ami models
now literally it's a convergence we like
to call it a democratization of data so
your analyst is super-powered with just
a little bit of sequel that you just
picked up on this one lab you can be
able to do just incredible things like
building your own machine learning
models so yeah the labs are great that's
that's why it's so fun to teach this
stuff so while those labs are while
those models are running I'm gonna ask
you in that first tab cycle back there
you know when it's done when you
actually go into the e-commerce I'm
toggling this open and closed and you
can see that my classification model
this first one is finished so I'm gonna
ask you to click on that one and we want
to see how well it did so I want you to
click on evaluation all this one's still
training I'm gonna go ahead and refresh
my browser and we'll see how many of
them finished there we go we got both of
them finished if you see it's still
training oh good both of them both arm
is still running so it looks like it
created this shell from the model but we
just don't need to wait for the queries
to finish yep - it tore is still running
so what are you going to see here let's
talk a little bit about the evaluating
the performance of a machine learning
model in the theory and by the way I've
been really lacks about doing this but
make sure that you actually click check
my progress for each of these including
creating the creating the datasets this
is how you get those speed bonus points
so let's talk about evaluating a machine
running model now you might ask how do
you know whether or not a classification
model is good or not and interesting a
scenario for classification models is
there's a couple different metrics you
can say a lot of people say accuracy if
my machine learning model is 98%
accurate is that a good thing so the
really cool learning part here is you
know the conversion rate for an
e-commerce website is about 2% so if
your model predicted that every single
new person is not going to buy very
simple model whatever the data that came
in it says this person's not going to
buy you would only be wrong 2% of the
time
that means you have a 98% accurate
machine learning model but is it any
good absolutely not because we have
what's called a class imbalance you know
you got only two percent of the people
in the positive class 98 percent of the
people in the negative class so accuracy
is not necessarily the best metric so
some other metrics one's called the
receiver operator characteristic or the
area under the curve I list link to some
Wikipedia articles and here for you to
learn about that all that essentially
means is you want to maximize the true
positive rate as fast as possible
meaning when I say they're gonna buy
they're gonna buy when I say they're not
gonna buy they're not gonna buy while at
the same time minimizing the false
positive rate and you want to maximize
if you remember your calculus you don't
have to do any that here but it's the
area under the curve the highest if you
can imagine this yellow curve right here
if it weighs fill up this entire square
it's just one by one so the area that is
one a 1.0 is perfect in the area under
the curve and that's what you can see if
it's greater than point nine it's good
essentially anything less than 0.7 is a
really terribly performing model so
let's go back and check on each of our
models and then it will do a quick
wrap-up
so back in bigquery I'm just gonna
refresh very quickly and you can see you
know let's see both models are done I
can see they're both running let's check
on the first model evaluation 0.78 again
we're looking for that super healthy
uptick for the precision and over time
so point seven eight can we do a little
bit better than that and again this is
at new as of a couple months ago that
they show you these graphs which is cool
and you can just copy and paste these in
your slide deck and just show hey I did
a model here's the evaluation 0.78
compared to 0.92 so you see just look at
the difference between the precision
recall curves and again it's still a
hard problem to solve so we're gonna
flip back between the two so this one is
a little hump and then way down this one
gives you a little bit more lift
but again perhaps we could add some more
features in the model and machine
learning is an iterative process you've
got to be comfortable with failure
that's essentially how the models works
it says all right I know this for the
path
here of my inputs am I gonna get a good
result based on running this over a
million records or not so it essentially
and what the process is called gradient
descent it will fail fail fail fail fail
until it gets at a point where okay cool
I think I've modeled the behavior of one
of these users effectively so you've
done exactly all the steps of machine
learning scientists would do the last
part is understanding the differences
between those two models so what did we
actually do so the only thing that we
did for the second model I asked you to
blindly run the code now I'm gonna
explain it to you a little bit more is
where you evaluated the performance of
the first one we already did evaluation
make sure you actually run the
evaluation query you can run you can get
those graphs either through this the
sequel or by clicking on the evaluation
tab if you're going for points make sure
that you actually run these and then
click the check points what did we
actually do so the second model it's the
exact same model code so at the top it's
the same model code same model type it's
not like we're using a neural network or
anything like that here but what we're
doing is machine learning models are
like you know spaceships and rocket
ships right they and the data is the
fuel if you're not healing them with
enough high-quality good training data
they're not gonna go anywhere so what
did we add well in addition to the time
on this side and whether whether or not
they left immediately we also added how
many pages they viewed where they came
from what traffic stores whether or not
they were on mobile or desktop what
country they came from and the good news
is you don't need to create a ton of if
statements if they're in this country
and they're on mobile and they've been
to six pages and they viewed this one
particular promotion then I think I want
to make them a promotion high level user
know if statement no case statement
logic just show the model the data and
let it through its magic behind the
scenes so that's one of my favorite labs
by the time you get to the end you can
actually make sure you created the
second model you can run the predictions
on new data by running that last
predictive query make sure you're
getting all the points and then you can
see actually the actual predictions that
it makes and the confidence in those
predictions
I'll leave that last part to you and you
can see the results there and I'll just
highlight that at the end you have
multiple labs that you can take multiple
times as part of this game every 12 for
this 12 hour period and we do games all
the time so twitter.com slash quick labs
every Friday we do one of these new
games which is pretty cool
and you can try try each of these
different labs so for example if your
background is more on the infrastructure
side and you want to work with
kubernetes this last lab is awesome you
can spin up a kubernetes cluster and
actually scrape reddit one of the
subreddits for like cute dog and cat
pictures and then display those in a web
app that you create so last thing before
I go you made it all the way to the end
I do want to share a promotional code
with you and I'll paste this into the
chat so the game is open for 12 hours
and you've got those five labs that show
me and I hand-picked to put in there but
what happens after the 12 hours ends you
can take more labs but kudos to you for
attending this webinar we're gonna give
you a 30 30 day free pass or one month
free if you have this link it's a little
bit hard to write down so I'll make sure
that I posted in chat but it's Google
Doc quick labs calm / quests / 23 and
the query string is quick labs campaign
and is one chord or a 30 day 96 so I'll
paste that in the chat I'll make sure
that we get that paste it into there so
make sure you don't leave with out the
link to the game the quick labs
promotion here and honestly just have a
blast
could we just quickly show them the
other higher education yes benefits as
well so if you're a student in higher ed
here are some links so you might want to
screenshot this and we'll make sure that
we put this information in the chat as
well we have some great career readiness
offerings that you can leverage to get
started with a discounter training and
certification as well so Evan and I have
thoroughly enjoyed our talk thanks to
the webinar crew here and Babita below
the our program coordinator nun Denis
our Ranga and our moderator this would
not have been
without the team support so thank you
very much for joining us and thank you
for tuning in please visit cloud on air
for more content from google cloud
experts and thank you Evan
it's have had a blast here working with
you today
my pleasure we'll see you in the game
good luck
[Music]
you